لذلك عندما تتأذى انتشار هذه الصواريخ
، لا تتأثر الحضارة
بل تتأثر بالارتباط لأن
الأنابيب هي الأكثر تضررًا من
كل شيء يتم غمر الأنابيب في
العديد من الأشياء وكم من الوقت
سيستغرق إصلاحها ستعود كما
ترى  لم يكن هذا هو نفسه ، كان هذا
هو ما إذا كان ما فعلته به
بالفعل قمنا بإصلاح الهيكل الذي قمنا بإصلاحه من قبل
البنك ، قمنا بإصلاح النظام ، قمنا
بتغيير كل شيء في سلسلة التوريد التي تتحرك
مثل القطار ومدة بقاء
الأشخاص  العمل هناك بشكل جيد ، أخبرني عن
هذه الثقوب هنا ، هذه من
الشظية ، هذه من أحد الخطوط
التي كان لها تأثير متعدد لها في المنزل ،
هذه القطع الكبيرة من الشظايا ، نعم ، هذا
يعطيك فكرة عن حجم
بعض الشظايا المتطايرة حولها.  هنا عمل
ثقوب ضخمة بحجم كف اليد مثقوبة في هذه
الأنابيب الفولاذية السميكة بسمك ربع بوصة
وهذا هو شراسة الهجوم